good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Rick
Dunham I'm White House correspondent for
Businessweek magazine and the president
of the National Press Club I'd like to
welcome Club members and their guests in
the audience today as well as those of
you watching on c-span or listening live
on National Public Radio the video
archive of today's luncheon is provided
by connect live and as an available to
members only website at WWF
Press Club members also can access free
transcripts of our luncheons on at our
website non-members may purchase
transcripts audio or video tapes by
calling 888 343 1940 and for more
information about joining the Press Club
the few reporters in here were not yet
members of the Press Club you can
contact us at 202 six six two seven five
one one before introducing our head
table I would like to remind the
audience of some future speakers
tomorrow our guests will be former US
senator Sam Nunn the co-chairman and CEO
of the nuclear threat initiative on
Tuesday March 15th one month before the
dreaded tax day Markey verse and the
Commissioner of the Internal Revenue
Service will address our members and on
Friday March 18th our speaker will be
levar burton actor and spokesperson for
the Children's Miracle Network and
coming up in April our guests will
include Jane Fonda and Senator Barack
Obama if you have any questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your table and pass them up
to me I'll ask as many as time permits
I'd now like to introduce our head table
guests and ask them to stand briefly
when their names are called please hold
your applause until all head table
guests are introduced from your right
jane Podesta of People magazine Layne
ball the senior public information
officer of the UN High Commissioner for
Refugees and without Elaine this event
would not be be taking place thank you
so much Elaine Steven Levitan of the New
York Times and co-chair of the National
Press Club freedom of the press
committee taylor kennedy of national
geographic john Fredrickson coordinator
of External Affairs for the UN refugee
agency and guests of our speaker Bob
Cardin of Cardon communications and the
speaker's committee member who
coordinated today
launched thanks Bob khalood a Doherty
the regional rep of the UN refugee
agency and a guest of our speaker bill
McCarran the president of us newswire
and chairman of the Press Club speakers
committee skipping over our speaker
Allison Bethel of the Detroit News and
National Press Club board member also
the winner of the President's Club award
for recruiting more new Press Club
members than any other individual in the
past year thank you very much Allison
next of Anna
Ian ouzo Avanza Elizabeth Talon
protection officer of the UN refugee
agency Casper's othon of yomiuri shimbun
mark Hamrick ap broadcast and vice chair
of the National Press Club Board of
Governors and Mark boy know of Dow Jones
a member of the National Press Club
president's Task Force on the Arts
wait throughout my year as National
Press Club president we will be hosting
well-known public figure is speaking on
important policy topics both domestic
and international that's why we're
delighted today to welcome Angelina
Jolie the goodwill ambassador for the
United Nations High Commissioner for
Refugees all of you know miss Jolie is
an Academy award-winning actress whose
work includes Girl Interrupted for which
she won an Oscar Golden Globe Screen
Actors Guild Award and many many more
gia and George Wallace for which she
also received Golden Globes Foxfire Bone
Collector I could go on and on and
upcoming mr. and mrs. Smith but as big
as stars she is miss Jolie is not here
to talk about her movie career but about
a subject very close to her heart the
plight of the world's estimated 717
million refugees since the summer of
2001 miss Jolie has traveled with the UN
refugee agency to some of the most
remote and desolate regions on the
planet meeting refugees in Sudan's
Darfur region sierra leone cote ivoire
kosovo and many other places her moving
an exceptionally well-written field
visit journal from Darfur is available
on the UN refugee agency website at UN
HCR org she's also written a book about
her work notes from my travels visits
with refugees in Africa Cambodia
Pakistan and Ecuador that sounds like
our speaker qualifies for a National
Press Club membership she's also
producing a moment in time a documentary
for which she sent cameras and
celebrities such as Jude Law and biling
to 38 locations around the world when it
comes to the plight of refugees she has
reached out to speak truth to power
around the globe recently at the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland
where she informed participants ranging
from bill gates to my colleagues at
Businessweek in October 2003 miss Jolie
was given the first UNCA citizen of the
world award by the UN Correspondents
Association the award cited her efforts
to bring forgotten refugee crises to the
attention of the world media our guest
is not only a dedicated advocate for
Refugees but a generous donor as well
funding many UNHCR initiatives and field
operations miss Jolie is in Washington
now to spearhead an initiative to
encourage law firms throughout
the country to donate more pro bono
legal work to refugees and refugee
issues in her travels mr. Li realized
that many children were not granted
asylum or other remedies because they
have no access to the US legal system
tonight she's the featured speaker at a
national video conference that will
outline the legal plight of child
refugees and ask law firms around the
country to give more time to the cause
and tomorrow night she and former
Secretary of State Colin Powell are
being presented with a Humanitarian
Award by the Kuwaiti foundation which
has raised more than a million dollars
for Iraqi refugees ladies and gentlemen
please welcome Angelina Jolie
thank you amazing um first of all thank
you so much for allowing me to be here
and and please help me maybe in a few
minutes will stop because I'm nervous
and I'll forget what I'm saying this
continues with the pictures but but
thank you so much for allowing me to be
here let me first I just like to mention
take this opportunity an important thing
that's happening in Congress today
later this afternoon the House
Appropriations Committee is voting on an
emergency bill to provide needed
assistance to victims of the tsunami as
well as displaced persons in Sudan and
other parts of Africa and I believe it
is it is a very important bill and I
hear that congressman Jesse Jackson jr.
is pushing for an amendment to restore
150 million dollars in food assistance
to Sudan that had originally been asked
for by the president
he's also proposing an additional
hundred million dollars of humanitarian
assistance for African emergencies so I
think it's very important and I hope
that the House committee does agree to
it back to why we're here for the last
four years I have met with refugees in
Africa Southeast Asia South America and
most recently in Darfur Sudan refugees
are some of the most amazing people and
especially the children many of them
have seen their families murdered in
front of them
they've lost their homes they've been
physically attacked themselves and yet
despite all of this somehow their
spirits are unbelievably unbroken and
most people don't realize that there are
over 50 million people in the world who
have had to flee their homes and half of
them are children so so why are we here
today two years ago I learned that every
year thousands of these children cross
into the u.s. alone without a parent or
a guardian and they come from all over
the world from China Ethiopia haida
haiti guatemala sri lanka from
everywhere
they're fleeing abuse poverty
persecution many of them have been
trafficked kidnapped and trafficked into
the United States and they're working in
sweatshops or prostitution rings they
cross into our border and they declare
I'm in fear for my life
and we lock them in centers and despite
they're very vulnerable situation these
children must then go to immigration
hearings alone they are not provided
with any legal assistance to help them
I've been to immigration court I can
hardly understand it I I can't I can't
believe that any of us would it would
expect that it's reasonable to send a
child to face this by themselves I
actually think it's cruel I strongly
support a bill called the unaccompanied
alien children child Protection Act of
2005 and that would help address the
critical needs these children have for
lawyers I know how difficult it is to
get legislation passed but these
children can't wait so to try to meet
the legal needs of these children sooner
than later we have established the
National Center for refugee and
immigrant children this Center will be
run by the US Committee for Refugees and
immigrants and the American Immigration
Lawyers Association the center will
recruit lawyers from around the country
to donate their time to help these
children so at this point I would like
to ask the directors of these two
agencies to please stand and be
recognized I think
I'm sure if you have any questions about
how the center will operate I'm sure
they would they would love to speak to
you and then I advise you to please do
that I'm also pleased to announce that a
number of law firms have already
committed to taking on a number of cases
pro bono and I'd like to take this
opportunity to mention them Haun denied
Freda Frank Dorsey and Whitney Morgan
Lewis Latham and Watkins Jenkins and
Gilchrist Fulbright & Jaworski Powell
and Goldstein Fager and Benson Maggio
and Qatar Spring and Spaulding we're all
very excited and and and really what
their commitment what their commitment
means is that already at least a hundred
kids will have some help and support
through this process that the sorts is
it's amazing can almost imagine the face
of the kids and it's really exciting
it's the point of all of this is is that
when children cross into this country
alone and they're scared we must hear
them out before we make a choice to
either allow them asylum in this country
or to send them away and it's unethical
not to listen to these children and for
those of you who say we do I say we
don't because without legal
representation we are sending children
to court to represent themselves in a
language that most of them don't even
understand and expecting them to recall
account so frightening and humiliating
that they wouldn't want to tell anyone
let alone a roomful of strangers if you
can imagine a boy who's been sexually
trafficked being asked to explain in
detail what's been done to him or a
twelve-year-old girl whose parents were
shot in front of her asking her to prove
it and recall every detail over and over
and over again and all we're asking is
for somebody to just hold their hands
through this really scary time these are
children
and I believe I have to believe that in
this country we don't turn our back on
innocent children and now we're pushing
for us to give him a chance to be
properly heard and you don't want that
for your children I certainly would want
it for mine so thank you very much for
listening today and I'm excited to talk
with everybody and continue to find ways
to to help these kids thank you
all right thank you very much we have a
large number of questions that range
from refugee kids in the United States
to Catherine the Great and Russia but
let me start out with something that was
that you were just talking about what do
you think will persuade congressman
sensenbrenner to pass the unaccompanied
alien Child Protection Act in the house
I'm gonna beg him right now I think he's
I think he's a smart man and he's got to
know that at the end of the day he's
certainly smart enough to understand
that at the end of the day it's a it's
it's smart for governments it's not for
our own government you know if you have
a caseload of children and you're saying
you know you want to get through these
cases and you want to know who's gonna
go back who's gonna stay how many our
prisons are gonna get full of of all
these cases and children in order to
deal with that you need this assistance
to move it forward for the judges to
understand the cases for us to be able
to understand these kids and whether we
send them back we don't we know whose
it's just it's it's it simply makes
sense so I think he's got to be smart
enough to uh to understand that if we
can't just simply appeal to him on a
humanitarian level do you think the
government should be funding the
National Center for refugee and
immigrant children or is this something
for the private sector this might I'm
gonna ask John Francis to come up but
but I do think I mean this what we're
talking about is a lot of pro bono work
as well so but yeah I mean clearly this
is an effort for both the private and
the governmental sectors the the the
bill that Angelina referred to on the
hill sponsored by senator Feinstein and
Senator Brownback does provide for the
capacity of the government to help these
pro bono organizations and law firms to
get involved so it doesn't provide for
direct legal representation per se which
is an issue in the law but it does
provide some governmental assistance to
make this possible for people to get
engaged and that's what we're seeking
for someone in the audience says I hear
that the Department of Homeland Security
separates parents from their children
and jails the parents and detention
facilities
apart from their children have you seen
this and what is UNHCR's position on the
separation of families I wall speak for
myself and not UNHCR I think that that I
think it's I think it's it's something
we really need to address I think it's I
think it's cruel I'll tell you a story
when I went to Arizona recently I went
to visit kids first I went to a shelter
and I met this young girl and I and and
like with the children we've just been
speaking about that they're
unaccompanied and I was really confused
because she was so alone and so scared
and and I found out she did have a
parent but her parent was locked in a
prison facility far away and then later
that day I met that parent and told her
that I had seen her daughter and she
broke down hysterically crying and these
two probably traveled through and God
knows what happened them in their
countries so horrible we can't even
imagine then they travel here then
they're separated so just just to think
about the the what that does to a kid's
mind what that does to them emotionally
what that does it's just that much more
damaging so um so I think there's got to
be a better solution I do think we need
to address it and you've seen around the
world a lot of refugee resettlement and
what the UN office of refugee
resettlement does how do you compare the
UN Office of refugee resettlement with
what the IRS does at the u.s. borders
well I know and then maybe I'm an ask
Elizabeth to help me to explain this
better I know there's been a great in
the last was last year there's been a
great shift from the food when these
kids came in used to be just the i ns
handling them and has been handed over
to the Orr and and there has been a lot
that has been addressed for these
children their accommodations they're
there where they're living what whether
it looks like a prison or whether it's
more of a more of a shelter for them and
and that's been a big deal and I think
we should all be very you know vocal
about how grateful we are for that step
forward for these kids and and that's
that's a positive step between the is no
are but
how do you feel about the Department of
Homeland Security's policy of fitting
asylum seekers with ankle bracelets to
track their movements in the United
States I I'll be honest it's the first
I've heard that and it's and it's it's
got it I just you know it's to be honest
I wish we lived in a world when we you
know people go every time I've seen
people cross into a country I've seen
refugees and I know the process you know
especially we've got lawyers and judges
looking at these cases they're working
very hard to separate who's really gonna
see getting asylum and and who is sent
back and if you have received asylum in
this country you have had to prove
something so horrible there is a reason
why you are here and you have been
through something that so then to have
to be further treated like a criminal I
just can't imagine that that's that
that's it at all fair decent I know that
this countries are scared right now and
we're all on you know it's a lot to talk
about terror but that's happening a lot
of other countries and there are things
in other countries where they can't
clean up so you know we we can we can
move on and we can start to address
terrorism fit something we're going to
fight overseas and other people are
addressing it daily and in their homes
in their neighborhoods so I think it's
easy for us to try to address things and
say we're scared here but we've got to
be a little a little more careful with
human beings lives and how they must
feel when they go through them like that
we have several questions from reporters
from around the world on your
impressions of various refugee
situations one asks about the Middle
East your impressions of the refugee
situation in the Middle East another
wants to know about your trip to Chad
and the people you met there and you
answered third already about Arizona
Chad I went to Chad quite a few months
ago and then most recently I went I went
into Darfur when I was finally allowed
to go in
therefore that's that's I think for most
it's such a complicated situation I've
got into so many refugee camps or
borders and and I mean it's so obvious
what the enemy is and and what the needs
are and and and this is a really
difficult situation when I saw people in
in Chad and then realized that they were
the lucky ones even though there's the
situation in the camp was so hard they
were looking for water and everybody was
in a panic to get them from one place to
another and get enough food and enough
care for the kids but then you realize
at least we knew where they were and
everybody could could it could start to
give them some assistance um it was the
millions of million people estimated if
not more that we're lost inside Darfur
then it's open we can get inside
therefore and I thought great we can you
know everybody can get these people in
you understand what the needs are I went
inside Darfur and I saw a lot of very
emotional very frustrated aid workers
who could not move and properly get to
the people and then when they could get
to the people they were concerned about
what they would give the people since
they were still living amongst the
people that had hurt them you know I
said met a group of kids and while I was
saying to them you know and then their
clothes were falling off them they had
no change of clothes they had medical
issues that clearly needed to be treated
and I'd say well what can you can't you
go to the medicals no the Janjaweed are
there you know can you tell me about
what's happened and while I was talking
them to Janjaweed men walked by with
guns and all the kids stop talking and
got really scared and refused to speak
to me anymore
so so this idea of are we really getting
in there to understand what's going on
and how are we really going to help them
it's really complicated and and I'm and
I feel for certainly for the people
there and also for the people there who
are trying to help them because I think
we need we need to do something bigger
with that situation and I'm not you know
I'm not a politician I don't know I
don't know the perfect answer but I know
that that to simply be sending a little
bit of a tour occasionally talking about
them or saying is it is it genocide is
it like Rwanda is it does it it's gross
human human rights violations and people
are dying every day so we've got to do
something more than we're doing right
now
yeah let's see we can talk about the
Middle East for a minute both first the
refugees in the Middle East but we also
got another question about Lebanon
saying you spent last Christmas with
refugees and the UNHCR staff in Lebanon
what are your thoughts about the recent
assassination of former Prime Minister
Hariri and what impact do you think his
assassination what has it had on you and
what do you think it will on the work in
Lebanon again I'm always so nervous
answering these questions because I feel
like I come from a place a from my heart
in my gut and I'm not I'm not the best
at analyzing these situations but I'll
tell you that when I was there for
Christmas with my son we I found it so
beautiful that we could see Christmas
trees next to mosques and and spend time
with all families and all different you
know backgrounds and everything you'd
say and you drive down the street and
see bullets on either side you see the
God these people were just fighting and
trying to kill each other now they're
friends and they're trying to rebuild
and they're celebrating together and I
we and it was I thought look what a
great example for this part of the world
so so for this to happen just it just
makes me feel like they God they were
getting so close to something and and
what I don't understand exactly what led
to it I don't know what's happening I
don't understand what's happening now
but but I'm in fear of what it's gonna
what how it's going to affect Lebanon
and the Lebanese people and what's gonna
happen them because they were so close
to something so peaceful and beautiful I
felt when I was there with my kid not to
get too much into into world politics
here but there's an interesting question
about the rumors that bono of u2 is
being considered to head up the World
Bank
I don't know if you've worked with them
at all on refugee issues but but first
do you think he'd be a good person for
that and secondly has your work for
UNHCR inspire you to consider either
running for an office or a another
position within the UN I think I got too
many skeletons in my closet for politics
but I think I have met Bono and I think
he is he's a great guy great family man
great and really genuinely is such a
such passion to do good things so so I
think but my choice for the World Bank
anything can you say these things I
guess you say in this room and it gets
out there would be would be a would be
compound so that's my choice
so I'll go from : Powell to one of his
former deputies we have more questions
on John Bolton than any other subject
today since that's it that's in the news
as the US the president's designee as
new UN Ambassador do you have any views
on John Bolton's nomination and do you
think that John Bolton at the UN after
John Negroponte and John Danforth would
change the u.s. approach to the UN I
really don't know I don't know nothing
I've started to watch watch and read
every things I can about him but but I I
can't really form an opinion I can only
hope that he's somebody who would be
truly because what we need is somebody
who's truly they're not to judge the UN
and but to try to really find the best
way to make it better and to work with
it and and and make the US and UN
relations better as opposed to just
coming at it with her with criticism so
I'm hoping that that's who he is there
are a couple of questions about Beyond
Borders first do you think Beyond
Borders could be used as for educational
purposes and second will you be
producing acting writing in more
awareness programs like Beyond Borders I
never know what's what's I we'd
certainly did that film because we loved
and we thought it said something I think
if people wanted to show it and use it
as education I think it's that would be
wonderful but everybody has a different
opinion about those things and I I did I
did recently a producer and I've never
spoken about this but a documentary and
I still don't know what it is yet I'm
editing it but but it was a moment in
the world and it was the idea was to try
to get a glimpse of of our world at one
time so we we sent 38 crews around the
world and from everywhere from war zones
refugee camps met with landmine victims
but also families in Middle America and
and just to get a sense of of what maybe
this world looks like and if people
could at least wake up and start to
think that way
so but I'm editing it now and I and I
don't know what it's gonna turn out to
be in and if anybody will watch it
beyond your own efforts how do you think
the movie industry has done has it
played a positive role in publicizing
the plate of refugees and specifically
what do you think Hotel Rwanda has done
for the issue
yeah well Hotel I absolutely loved Hotel
Rwanda I think it's most important film
that came out this year and I know Don
Cheadle has recently been to Darfur and
he's become very very active and I think
he's even working with Paul Rusesabagina
who Hotel Rwanda is about on something
that the campaign I believe he's even
called Hotel Darfur so so he continues
not just with the film they both are
continuing to be extremely active
because they see the parallels there's
also a beautiful film I am David that
was about a refugee boy but certainly I
would love it if you know I've read I
read scripts all the time and most of
them don't don't have very much to say
and I've done some of those but I wish
their I wish there were more and I also
wish that audiences wanted to see those
films because often films are made for
what what audiences want audiences don't
seem to be rushing the theaters often to
see really really heavy things but but
hopefully we can change that and do more
what do you think the United States the
United Nations and other leading powers
could do to prevent future genocides
like was portrayed in Hotel Rwanda and
do you what can they do
for the plight of refugees I think this
is it's a bigger question I've recently
I've recently traveled to Ethiopia with
Jeffrey Sachs and I've been learning
about the Millennium Development Goals
and you know many people think they're
very very ambitious and I believe they
are but I think they're also possible
the reason I bring those up is because
the idea of how much money when I
started to look at statistics and how
much money we sent in in aid and after
the fact and let's fix it with the war
you know and or there's this many
refugees have fled across the border or
this wars
these people are fighting over resources
I think we all need to be focusing on
helping these people to be able to
control their own resources have proper
quality of lives understand their soil
understand their school for their
children understand all of these things
so there will be simply less conflict in
the world and therefore less refugees
and and less need for food and we can
start just investing in people and their
infrastructures and and I think that's
what we should all be and all
governments should be focusing on the
recent tsunami was universally described
as a huge tragedy and a galvanized
actions from governments and citizens
around the world what does it take to
move nations and people to act whether
it is a natural disaster or a human
disaster well I think the press can help
it's what you focus on that helps the
people to know what they should be
believing is important and should be
paying attention to I think the the
thing we should all that I'm certainly
very aware of is the tsunami with
something there's nothing you know it's
not man-made if something happens
something that we could do nothing about
to prevent these other things we're
speaking about where millions of people
are dying are we can stop them they're
man-made you know why are we spending so
much why don't we completely understand
that and the numbers of kids that die
I don't I think it was the world was you
you you know more than I do about the
number of of people that died that died
in the tsunami that number is a matter
of weeks of people who die of hunger so
that's what we need to think of how how
do we do or what can be done to improve
conditions in the countries from which
refugees are fleeing is there a way to
deal with the issues before the refugee
situation is created particularly if it
second economic rather than political or
can we just treat the symptom after the
people have fled the countries
absolutely you know and they're back to
to rebuilding infrastructure and
focusing on on the countries before
before they break apart into such
conflict and and such desperation so so
absolutely I mean I'm trying to do that
and when I Cambodia and then you know
the families that I work with and and
and around the world I think and you
know I when I went for example with the
Millennium Development Goals people they
went we went to one village and and this
they they had malaria ologist soil
experts people who understood solar
power economists everybody and they
could flood that area and walk around
and understand and have a lot of answers
to really do it from the ground up as
opposed to I think now we often you know
send one person and to maybe address one
issue or somebody else or we're know but
we're not all working coordinated that's
for you and agencies and governments and
NGOs and the more we can work together
to to really do things from the ground
up is the answer I believe we've several
questions about China and North Korea
which is I guess we could say an
emerging refugee issue one person asked
what do you think about China turning
back North Korean refugees to North
Korea knowing that they are sending them
to prison camps and/or death sentences
I'm seeing myself on that now and hoping
to take a trip to visit them so
hopefully maybe I'll be able to answer
that better and more publicly in the in
the months to come but I think it's
something we all must clearly pay
attention to there are a couple of
questions about lawyers and the
initiative that you are in town to work
on one came in by email from London
asking once the children would gain
asylum if they if they have the benefit
of lawyers what extra rights would you
like to see them have once they have
gained asylum I had rather than just
being in a country and then being all
alone is there anything else that we
need to do for them I think I think I'm
sure guardians and and and helping them
to understand it's like most refugees
they come here it's helping them and
like the Lost Boys of Sudan I think they
we all know about
we know they first came they didn't
understand doorknobs they didn't
understand certain basic there's lots of
things to help somebody learn about a
new country certainly a kid and also I
think we know children at school there's
going to be a lot of you know cruelty
and judgement and I think something we
should be doing also anyway is is really
looking at our school systems and how
best to get our teachers explained as
the kids about other cultures other
heroes and other countries and and
getting the kids to start to speak about
their differences opposed to just we're
all American now and let's ignore them
so I think that's that's something that
would help the children coming in but I
think we also need to look at the rights
for children born in this country which
which needs some some help as well for
those of us who are not lawyers what
would you recommend that we do to help
this cause well I'm not a lawyer and I
mean I I'm having the same I wish I was
because I could do more visit the
children if you can I think a lot of
kids just simply our children hear them
alone I I know certainly paying
attention and making people aware or
pressing law firms to donate their time
but if you personally wanted to just I'm
sure spend time with these kids bring
them teddy bears get listen to them you
know just be a friend there alone so the
there there are many things you could
you could do make make friends with them
I hope we have a couple of questions
about the National legal Resource Center
was there anything any specific moment
or event or series of events that
inspired you to donate to the National
Legal Resource Center for aiding
unaccompanied children seeking asylum
and did your experience with adopting
your son Maddox have any impact on your
decision to do this I'm sure it did at
some point because my my son's country
the highest number of children
trafficked from Cambodia are trafficked
for begging so when I was last in
Thailand and you'd realize that all the
kids in the street you they don't speak
Thai they speak Khmer and they were
probably trucked out that morning by
somebody too so
so clearly um you know I'm aware of
these kids and think my son could easily
have been one the really what I went to
visit Arizona and I was with John and
Elizabeth and and we were we had been
speaking to different people on the hill
about this bill and and I just couldn't
understand how this was happening to
these kids it just made me uh I was sick
about it and then we just thought well
this is crazy we you know we all I need
to start working together and who are
the best people and who are already
doing everything they can to help these
kids and let's find them let's pull
together and let's come up with some
idea to do something substantial today
so that's really kind of how it look a
man do you plan to or hope to adopt more
children yes absolutely
um my sons bear my sons in love with
Africa
so he's been asking for an African
brother or sister now we know about the
accuracy of news media reports but one
question came in said recent media
reports said you had tried to adopt a
Russian orphan and were denied
permission is that true and do you have
any views on the Russian orphan
orphanage system which now has 700,000
orphans more than following World War
two
I wasn't it uh I'm always by the way
almost any country I go to him prepared
to his jobs but but I wasn't at that
time I went for for humanitarian reasons
and I went to visit the children in
Basel and it was the 40-day anniversary
and I was the hospital and I also went
to orphanages and and and and now I am I
wasn't denied any kind of any kind of
adoption but but then when I saw a
picture of this kid which I you know
didn't know and thought god that's
amazing um they would do that and I
still wonder how that kid is and where
that you know if somehow the press did
something with the with this unknown
child and and how his life's been
affected by that so that's just another
example of how the press needs to be so
careful because you know what does that
mean for for his future if he's been so
publicly
you know turned into some story that
there's nothing to it but now he's out
there and who is he any little kid what
motivated you in 2001 to get involved
with the refugee issue and how did it
come about that you became goodwill
ambassador I was I went to shoot shoot a
film in Cambodia and it was the first
time you know I grew up in the States
I've had a pretty good education I did
but I really didn't I was not educated
about other countries and other
histories properly I believe as many of
our countries or not and I went to
Cambodia and I was shocked I didn't
understand you can't you can't shoot
over there and please don't walk over
there because there are landmines and
and then I'll you know this is what a
refugee is and these these people that
they've all returned from this area and
this is yes the the prisons and and I
just it was very clear to me that there
was a lot about this world that that I
didn't know and I felt I felt really
ashamed and ignorant but that I didn't
and that I had to start educating myself
and I had also been following what was
going on in Sierra Leone at that time
when I was I was in England and then I
came back to the States and I couldn't
follow it as well so I called I I got a
bunch of books on every different NGO
and every different UN agency and I read
the chapter on UNHCR and there was 20
million people were refugees and I
thought what years this that's got to be
the most impossible that's what wouldn't
you know and and then realised and and
and I called Washington and said you can
I think I'm completely crazy but I'm an
actress and I just likes to learn and
can you help me and they I went to
Washington and spoke with them for quite
a long time and then a few weeks later I
was in Sierra Leone and I travel with
you and a chair for about a year
learning about them and I'm learning
about me before before we agreed to to
work together and speak about it and it
just changed my life that leads into the
next question which is how did the
humanitarian work alter your perspective
on life
it's given you know I think at the end
of the day we're all we're all alive to
get to know ourselves and each other
better and to be of some use in this
world and when I was growing up I felt I
didn't really feel very good about
myself I was I was
and later came to realize it was because
I really was not abused to others so it
focused me on on on life and and and
also just I met refugees and and these
people that had gone through so much and
I would had woken up you know in my own
just worried about you know traffic or
my family or or some stupid job or
something and then you get to a place
and you realize how lucky we all are and
and I since have not complained about
anything stupid or superficial since and
and I'm very very aware of what we
should what should be our priorities and
and there can you talk a little about
activism in Hollywood do your
contemporaries really care either
Hollywood in general and then the then
your generation of stars in Hollywood
and who do you have a lot of respect for
for the kinds of things they're doing
for humanitarian causes god I you know I
I do think a lot of the people in in in
the film business are just simply having
traveling they just don't know and I and
I do believe they're good people at
heart many of them and if they were more
aware they do more I have to believe
that there are a lot of good people I'd
you asked me different people I know I I
don't actually know many we don't kind
of get together and so but I do think
Bono has been doing some great things
and and and yeah it's quite a few could
a few other other actors a recently Brad
Pitt went to went to Ethiopia and
I know when I was doing the documentary
and I'd ask people would they go to
Chad's young kid Ryan Gosling said yes
I'd love to learn and someone else went
to Kosovo and someone else but they all
came back and emotional and different
than them so so yeah I do I do think I
do think they have it in them and then
they will do more and especially if
they're encouraged and not criticized
when they first take that step because I
think that often happens in the press we
see somebody do something and
immediately it's you know just they shot
down so they get shy and go back inside
so maybe a little encouragement would
help next question is want to know why
BusinessWeek editors would like me to
answer that is how do you balance your
day job with your extracurricular
activities there's it's become a very
fuzzy line as which is which now because
um I haven't actually worked for for the
last few months and I'm having more
trouble going to I think this has kind
of taken over my life more more than
than anything else and I'm very happy
about that so hopefully I'll be doing a
little less film work and and a little
more of this right now but you know end
of the day I'm a mom and that's my life
so last night I was running around
trying to do things and my son was
spilling food all over my speeches and
somehow we cleaned it up and I'm here so
but but that's a you know I think you
find balance when you're happy and you
on the things you really care about and
so it's it's it's it's for kind of my
it's a joy there were a few questions
that slipped in about your film career I
was wondering what you're most proud of
that that you have done of you've won
Academy Awards many others what what do
you like most of what of what you have
done so far I don't watch my own films
I'm a terrible judge of my you know
reason I did an animated film and my son
thinks I'm cool so that was but but you
know the interesting thing is I I was
saying earlier that I've done films that
in this business are you know Ted had
some good good critique and some have
been completely panned as as crazy like
you know Tomb Raider films are not
considered
you know these really deep films but I
can go to the middle of Asia and Africa
and make a little kid smile because he
recognized it and so they're my
favorites someone wanted to know about
Catherine the Great and what what what
made you take that role and if you enjoy
playing a historically misunderstood
character it's extremely misunderstood
because I'm actually not playing it's
you know it's a funny there's so many
bizarre rumors I've been fighting that
one for a long time I don't know where
that came from but but I'm not playing
I'm sure she's fascinating and and I'd
love to play I'm not so well we know
about believing everything you read in
the papers have you ever considered just
going and going and in doing a movie of
fiction movie about the kinds of things
you're working on for on refugees or do
you think the documentary route and the
book route is the best way to highlight
it I think for now certainly
documentaries are because I think
there's nothing more powerful you can't
recreate in a film what these people and
these children are really like so the
real situations I think are just much
more powerful and so probably
documentaries now we have various
various questions about what's going on
at the US border survive if I can swing
back over there is there anything else
that you would like to see the US
government do or Congress do other than
the legislation that that we discussed
that you're going over to Capitol Hill
to talk about are there any other
priorities that you think either the
federal government or Congress can can
adopt that would make a difference with
refugees at the u.s. borders
there are actually many different things
but what I've learned visiting
Washington a few times is you have to
stay very focused on at least one thing
at a time and bridges it through so so
yeah my mind is on lots of lots of
different things I'm I've become aware
of and I will become more vocal on but
as of now I'm just going to keep
shouting this one to make sure it goes
through other than the issue that we
touched on with North Korea are there
other Forgotten refugee problems that
haven't gotten a lot of attention that
you'd like to shine a little bit of a
spotlight on are there areas in the
world that you think are underreported
with the problems of the plate of
refugees there are so many UNHCR works
in over 110 countries so pretty much
everywhere in the world where have the
Congo because I've been there quite a
few times and I and I know it's been
exploding again and worried about that
situation I'm worried about the
situation in Burma or Myanmar to be
politically correct but and the people
inside the internally displaced persons
inside that area I'm very worried about
them and I think none of us really know
what's going on it's gonna and I'm
afraid I don't want it to be like my you
know the situation in Cambodia where we
discovered too late how many lives were
lost and how horrible it was and I do
think that's what's going on inside
there yet southern Sudan so then that's
where internally displaced but you gone
that they're there many child soldiers
is is something that I think and you
asked earlier there's gonna be something
to address that as I mentioned Uganda
that that is something that I think um
well what are the common threads you see
with children that you meet refugee
children around the world and how are
there differences when you are in
Cambodia or in Africa or in Europe with
Kosovo we're what are they what are the
similarities and and what are the stark
differences that you may see from
situation to situation
you know things that might sound cliche
the kit the kids are the same everywhere
the kids uh if they're young kids
they're still really smiling and happy
because they don't understand where they
are they're not quite aware of how much
they're missing the the thing that was
interesting when as I've traveled is
that and we know how kids are in this
country you asked me getting ready to go
to school and they can't fight you and
they don't go and across the the world
in refugee camps they're begging to get
a chance to go to school they they work
really really hard they they're like
little adults they've been through so
much and then you ask them what they
want to be and they say I want to be a
doctor because I want to help my people
I want to be an architect because I want
to rebuild my country I'm they're very
unfortunately they're very very focused
on the needs survival but you know
because of that they've become
remarkable remarkable strong smart clear
good people out of them and and I think
if we if we give them the right guidance
young then they will continue to grow in
a positive direction I think if we don't
aid them by the time they're nineteen
twenty and they've seen a lot of death
and they've had no opportunities you
know then you start to worry about if
they've if they've developed and into
and gone and more angry place and then
we don't want that to happen and it
doesn't happen if we if we take care of
them as they've grown up how have you
seen your son grow and change from the
time you met him as a refugee to now
someone who has had some familiarity
with Western culture and like can't say
Hollywood life a sort of average
American life but with with with life in
the West
well my we travel I'm gonna make a point
I think the best education I can give
him is to just show him the world as I
know it as I see it now which is which
is to keep traveling so he spends he's
got two passports and he spends most of
his time in other countries we have a
home in Cambodia he he loves you know
Asia Africa and and we actually don't I
don't bring him to a lot of he does come
to set and he comes to work with me but
you also
you know point to Africa and he'll say a
mommy goes there or he knows you know
he's very he's very aware he understands
we have landmine victims or our
neighbors in Cambodia and he understands
what that is and and he and he
understands that there are kids that
don't have any food or don't have any
parents and don't
he hasn't understood that he was one of
them yet but you know recently we went
to Ethiopia we went to a market and he's
three and a half and and he was just
walking around no tort no other tourists
and he was just walking around talking
to everybody and sitting on their labs
and and I thought that's great it's that
he's learned the most important thing he
doesn't see a difference he's enjoying
these people and he's you know they so
that's you were in at least one film
that dealt with modern politics Wallace
I was wondering if there any figures out
there in the current world the in the
contemporary political world you think
would be you would be interested in in
playing down the road or if you think
they're any larger than life figures out
there you think would be good subjects
no I'll let you guys decide that one
I couldn't possibly see myself way
better though of looking back over over
over the past decade there's been a big
big change in Hollywood big change in
the media in terms of cable and where
people go from for movies where they
could go for entertainment do you think
we're gonna see more more and more
people watching at home do you think the
movies that you did for HBO or a wave of
the future or do you think we're going
to have curved parallel worlds with the
big-screen movies and people who watch
on the small screen at home
the combination of technologies you mean
like the yeah I mean I'm like I said I'm
really terrible at all that stuff I'm
talking about understanding theatres and
box I wasn't thinking how um but uh but
I do think it's interesting that that
you can you know you don't have to go to
the theater and have you can sit at home
rent a movie I think it makes all films
more accessible to people and I think
that's great
but I don't know I think it's best when
you're in the business never to think
about that song okay
can just work before we ask the final
question I'd like to thank you for being
here today and present you with two
souvenirs of your appearance
one is the coveted National Press Club
mug and a certificate of appreciation
which I'm sure will not quite go up
there next to the Academy Award but is
suitably framed
and now the final question one of our
enquiring international correspondence
asks did you choose to go by the name of
Sholay because it means beautiful in
French or I will add because that was
your middle name at birth
Oh an easy question yeah that was my mom
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo Anjali
Julie she she was hoping for a pretty
angel I said I meant and got stuck with
a bit of a wild child but um but but I
never actually like Julie coz because of
what it meant it always made me a butt
but now it's my son's name so so it's
ours and it's cool and I like it so
thanks mom
all right thank you very much
I'd like to I'd like to thank all of you
for coming today I'd also like to thank
National Press Club staff members
Melinda Cook Pat Nelson Joann boos and
Howard Rothman for organizing today's
lunch also thanks as always to the NPC
library for its research were adjourned
thank you very much
everything
thank you thanks for thanks for asking
the close of the party erection
thank you good luck in all the work I
know yeah I go for it very cool
you probably got my email last night or
this morning
yeah